the arrow points down but the sign urges
caution after five consecutive days of
fewer and fewer new deaths Spain saw a
sharp increase in coronavirus fatalities
on Tuesday
nonetheless the rise was attributed to
weekend deaths only now being recorded
and that overall the trend remains
downward Spanish firefighters are
playing a vital role in support of the
medical professionals fire crew
volunteers are decontaminating
ambulances and other public authority
vehicles which have been carrying
coronavirus patients the most important
of esters for their the most important
thing we can do is give our best to the
situation there are many different
groups working and the most important
are the public health workers who are
moving mountains we must give all we
have because we're going to win we are
going to beat this in the French capital
Paris city authorities have now banned
outdoor exercise between the hours of
10:00 a.m. and 7:00 p.m.
amid concern that too many people were
just using it as an excuse to go outside
police are stepping up enforcement as
total French fatalities from the virus
past 10,000 on Tuesday president macaron
was listening to the concerns of medical
center staff one detailed how a lack of
protective gowns is the main problem
here the most well thought-out plan
didn't predict that China would be
hittin that all countries would have the
peak at the same time and the protective
materials we thought were of no value
six months or one year ago was the most
idiotic thing to do and all of a sudden
were in trouble
the pandemic continues to challenge
European democracy and Poland's
right-wing government is pressing on
with presidential elections next month
despite a chorus of public and political
opposition the plan still needs Senate
approval but there were bitter exchanges
in the lower chamber yesmy political
stood I'm ashamed that I am sharing the
Parliament floor with people like this
people who are insensitive to those who
are begging for help today mothers
fathers entrepreneurs workers you are
losing yet another day just for the sake
of holding on to power coronavirus has
generated new respect and affection for
the medical staff on the front line of
the outbreak and on tuesday world health
day as designated by the
uho its director-general urged more
recruitment to address staff shortages
one of the lessons I hope the world
learns from copied 19 is that we must
invest in nurses and midwives without
them the world would indeed be in a very
dark place right now
Paul Brennan al-jazeera